[Music]
you weren't even like going to the song
at all you just
it was a freestyle version
it was a freestyle version i love it oh
my god
okay well
you'll notice the audio setup is a bit
different we had to change everything
well yeah
um we have long story short we have
better audio now but it's going to be a
bit clunky for a while as you can see
the board is sitting here on the table
and we're still
kind of drowning in equipment here
running in the equipment
we are drowning in equipment and you
guys could be drowning in wine right now
when you start up with wink oh my god
wink delivers wine
right to your front door they pick out
the best tasting wine that's perfect
just for your palette okay and they're
right now they're giving you 20 off your
first order when you go to try wink
that's t-r-y-w-i-n-c-d
they'll even cover shipping check them
out really really really awesome peeps
and an awesome service also guys
join lyft the ride sharing company that
believes it's treating their people
better they do everything they can to
make sure drivers are happy on every
trip and right now they're looking for
drivers they're looking for you guys
they're looking for you
they're looking for you right now you
can now
go to lyft it's nice right
lyft.com you get yourself a new 500 new
driver bonus limited time only check
them out okay i want control
we will get back to the sponsors first
of all i'm on the other side today
hopefully it didn't give too many of you
guys like a shock because he wants to
use the bowl i don't want to use it i'm
trying to make sure this whole thing
works because we're recording on the
computer
and recording video on the camera which
is a new thing for us
it's actually a new thing but it's how
we started the podcast do you remember
that yeah we used to have the laptop
here recording our shitty usb mics and
now we have
the audio quality should sound a lot
better now like we have came full circle
we have came full circle we have came
i want to
leave we have kids
yeah okay we're gonna turn on the high
voice for jenna wow
wait is this the one i like oh yeah i
like this one
okay you'll have that you'll have the
voice and i won't oh
perfect okay
um so
that's not funny nothing so funny
we're in a weird moon tonight whenever i
hear like laughter in this it makes me
laugh yeah and then it's like a laugh
circle tell me tell me what you like to
eat a lot of just say i like to eat a
lot of and then give me
[Applause]
uh i like to i like to eat a lot of
ramen
cool i also like pizza
cool
my name is yeah i have a basketball game
tomorrow
i like to eat the blood of my enemies
sir
sorry
what else you got in there what else you
got oh you got games on your phone
can i play snake on your phone
oh
yeah all right what's this one called
this is just pitch change pitch change
you like the karaoke one i like the
karaoke one it's dope as [ __ ]
my name is troy i have a basketball game
tomorrow
okay does it record this like inner
voices or is this whole podcast just
gonna be us laughing at nothing i'm
almost positive it's recording it
exactly how it sounds let's just
have a bathroom tomorrow
wait why did you shut it up because i um
i was getting nauseous and i was gonna
throw up on top of my microphone like
honestly you're nasty and you need jesus
i have jesus in my pocket pocket cheese
speaking of pocket cheese this episode
of jenna julian podcast brought to you
by pocket jesus never go anywhere
without jesus in your pocket sorry
that's not how it's no okay so someone
actually i had to introduce it in that
way i had to segue into the introduction
someone suggested in the comments that
we have like a segway off so i was
thinking of like how we can do that
because julian is far more experienced
in the segwaying than i will ever be
and he does the the um sponsors every
week and his fire segways are nothing
short of legendary
but so i figured we put some oh there's
like one or two real things in there but
uh we put some fake products or sponsors
into a cup sorry about that
what the [ __ ]
that's just your computer telling you
yeah we it might not have recorded i
don't know we'll see um we put some fake
and real sponsors in the cup and the
goal the game is
we're gonna have a conversation
we have to seamlessly weave all of our
sponsors into the conversation but we do
have two real sponsors lyft lift and
wink by the way guys are the sole
sponsors of this podcast this episode
the other ones are fake it's not real so
every time we tell you
to go buy something or
you know whatever.com slash and
jillian's fake unless it's wink or lift
okay this is a fake podcast the rest of
the sponsors are fake look at look at
what your daughter is doing what is she
doing she's laying on the table what is
she what is she though she looks like a
giraffe she is she's my giraffe she's
not a giraffe okay are you ready to draw
you i love how you graduated from moving
your own mic to moving my mic i know i
know i'm such a control for i'm sorry
babe that's annoying i'm really sorry
okay
go ahead why don't you pick out your
first big sponsor i'm gonna get my ass
handed to me in this okay do i look at
it now yeah okay
i think so yeah so then we can know
um this one is melatonin protein shakes
by bodybuilding.com
so you can
have a nice relaxing post workout no no
no no no no
all right i got oh my god tampax extreme
sport oh my god
okay
i'm not gonna be good at this you gotta
try babe i got
jared's caiman jerky
if you were here last episode jared is
the poor cayman rest in peace we got eat
on the uh show the wheel we named him we
named him jared it's just some guy
killed a little baby cayman and we
decided his name was jared
jared this boy eating jared and his name
is spelled
j-a-r-a-a-d
german oh i got coca-cola
boring
but that could be that could also be
really good classic all right
oh
rat poison
i wanted that one too i'm getting all
the good ones
damn it
you're not even gonna let me open mine
damn it can we trade audio technica
speaker sports here i'll take that one
yes audio technica speaker sports
it's a speaker built into your sport
elmer's hot glue flip flops
i'm gonna lay mine out right here but
you can't look at them okay
wait but i still need one more yeah you
have one more
all right i got elmer's hot glue flip
flops
and my last one is i forgot the last one
is
all natural lamb skin condoms nice
that's a real thing though right damn it
yours are like better than mine and
you're better at segways like i'm set up
to fail
damn it all right when they're counting
you out
and you're set to fail
that's when you gotta dig deep dig real
deep
all right you come out of winter you dig
deep
you have to dig deep
and the odds are against you
sky high
everyone's banking on you to lose
because you think
they think you're a loser
but you're not a loser you need to
believe in yourself
and every meal counts
which means every meal
no
all right no you're not you i was i was
honestly just trying to lift your
spirits
if you had gone somewhere with that like
we i feel like we have to judge each
other if it was successful yes the other
person has to approve the segway
[Laughter]
[Music]
can you please put some voices on yeah
let's put some voices on
oh my god what do we got
oh hell yeah
we we
oh is this phaser this is phase no it's
not i like this my name is troy i have a
basketball game tomorrow
i'm a point guard so we were talking
when brett was here last weekend we
literally sat down
we like had no alcohol nothing we were
just hanging out and uh
we decided to watch some of nightmare
fuel
yeah like julian's album all right this
is nominating yeah we uh we turn on
nightmare fuel yeah
which is conveniently packaged into one
video on my youtube channel so
but so we like well because i saw on
twitter someone tweeted at me nightmare
fuel all at once and they took all of
your songs and laid them on top of each
other and made one just awful sounding
which i don't know how i can ever thank
that person enough for doing that yeah
but i mean speaking of laying things on
top of each other you can get yourself
some elmer's hot glue flip-flops because
it's hot glue layered on top of itself
and then you get flip-flops
my god i know how you feel now
i don't know how to feel it i feel like
i've been taken for a ride
yeah you're like
wait was the conversation we just had
does that mean anything to you or were
you just thinking about it
now you know how it feels it is brutal
that's brutal
i i don't know how to feel i honestly
don't that was did i do it you did it
that was an incredible thing
by the way the reason why i even wrote
this down as a thing was because i saw a
hack video online hot glue hacks it was
on [ __ ] facebook which i'm never on i
really was angry about in the first
place
but it was like hot glue hacks and some
of them were just the most garbage trash
ass [ __ ] i've ever seen one of which was
he literally took a piece of cardboard
and just
hot glue it all over it and and then let
it dry and then decided that they were
shoes
um i was like boy if you don't anyways
we sat down and we watched a lot of
nightmare fuel because i was trying to
find nightmare fuel all at once yeah
and um
that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] funny yeah i
like it's not funny if you hear it all
the time but it's funny if you go back
and listen to it it's also funny in the
least like cerebral way ever it's just
like you're in a weird mood you want to
laugh and that it's that kind of funny
um i'm going to lower your levels a
little bit if you want to put your mic a
little bit closer peaches grow on trees
but what grows in my house you listen to
all the songs and it like
just pooping everywhere everywhere
everywhere why'd you leave us hanging
why didn't you do a nightmare a
nightmare fuel volume too and i didn't
have an answer for that
why haven't you made another one i i
need to make it it's not like it's a
particularly long process to make them
you made that like a weekend you know
what the physical manifestation of
nightmare fuel happened in a weekend
but what led up to the substance of that
being a reality i know it's coming
i'm just trying to talk
led up to that being a real thing
takes months an artist process cannot be
rushed
months
like like 2015 or something months
you don't know what's going on in here
during that time it's like
what would make you think that i'm
looking at my sponsors don't do it no i
honestly did i thought about nightmare
field for a long time and before it
actually happened
you take to get to to there
we are in las vegas
yes
yes okay eating our wonderful hotel room
service
and i was trying to eat more and faster
but all i have for forks and match
and i just needed some audio technica
speakers forks
so i didn't have to switch
cutlery during my meal and i also kind
of listened back to the nightmare fuel
from the sport because audio technica
now makes speakers forks
guys audio technica okay you go to
audiotechnica.com get your speaker
sporks and that that way you can eat
every sort of food
they now come in chopstick sports
speakers too so you can eat every sort
of food and have a bluetooth speaker
playing in the background
i'm sorry yeah you're such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] hater i am i am not yes i am
such a [ __ ]
oh my god julian that was really good i
mean i saw it coming a little bit but
that was
i mean thank you i mean you're good at
what you do what can i say i you know
i'm a man of few talents and when i'm
good at those things i'm going to be
good at them
talents um i'm i'm really really good at
falling asleep with the light on
sometimes
like i pretty much don't even turn off
the lights ever
i sleep with them like completely on
uh
i'm also really good at um hitting my
shin on the bed when i go to the
bathroom in the morning that's true i do
that i do that well what you just said i
also am really good
at
hydrating
i want to take them away from you i'm
good at hydrating take your daughter
she's so hot dog give me a dog i'm good
at dogging i have a good dog she is a
good dog why are you so floppy
why is she such
you just said that you're really good at
falling asleep with the lights on which
reminded me that michael lopria already
said earlier that domino's was pizza for
vampires that's so funny
because nobody really like orders at
least like in a city no one really
orders dominoes like
by choice it's always because they're
open super late and it's like you're
that hungry you need something to eat
well if you think about it like we've
i've had you know before
first of all
before i went vegan right
i had a couple bouts with domino's which
i failed miserably and i hate dominoes
for it never gonna eat dominoes again
but you know i tried it a couple times
they introduced a gluten-free pizza uh
it turns out it wasn't really
gluten-free and it got me sick pretty
bad a couple times but there were a
couple times where i had domino's pizza
and i'm thinking of a couple different
places what
i'm not i'm not doing anything you know
it goes
really great
it's a nice cold
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
a bottle of caffeine free diet coke
only caffeine
is in a gold bottle
i'm like literally crying cries through
whole segway
can't open my eyes or do anything
my mom is one of the only people i've
ever met my entire life that by choice
drinks caffeine-free coca-cola my father
does that too i'm like
what the [ __ ] are you drinking that for
it's the gold can right yes
oh it's gnarly
you're drinking she drinks decaf coffee
and caffeine-free coke
there's no point it's wild there's no
point it's wild you might as well use it
to poison rats which if you have rats
guys get rat poison because rat poison
dot com slash jenna julian is giving you
100
pounds of rat poison damn
you got a lot of rats if you go to
ratpoison.com the moment you go to that
url the rat poison will be arriving at
your house at that time oh damn
and they'll i don't know i think that's
like when it was too close to mine so
glad all right fine
i really wanted rat poison because i
wanted to start talking about something
and then you should drag that rat and
then after that you should poison that
rat try to bring that back do i have to
redo that one no
i just lost it yeah my how was mine
yours was great except for the fact that
you cried through the whole thing
it's a rat poison i lost i that was too
bad
it was okay it was okay
okay not your final work not your finest
work i lost it it's fine don't leave
that on the ground it's totally fine
okay what's fine i don't really want to
be here anymore
i don't want to be here
no i honestly and i i don't feel like
driving so i'm just going to hop up and
grab a lift
and you know what's funny oh my god
that's one of the reasons
why you did that right now you guys join
lyft you could be picking me up imagine
that i mean that's not what they told me
to market it but just
live in l.a that might happen but lyft
is looking for new drivers right now
guys and if you sign up right now
are we halfway through the week you can
get a 500 new driver bonus
new driver bonus okay lyft is the
ride-sharing company that believes in
treating its people better guys happy
drivers and happy passengers no surprise
nine out of ten lift rides get a perfect
five-star rating okay i take lips all
the time love my experiences everyone's
always so nice okay so if you're ready
to earn hundreds of dollars per week
plus tips drive for lift with expressway
you get paid almost instantly instantly
and lyft is the first ride sharing
platform to integrate tips right into
the app you keep 100 of the tips and
lift drivers have been paying over 200
million dollars since tips were
introduced to the app
they've even made pickups of breathe
breeze they have
color coded amp signs so you know what
is with the with the light on their
thing it's so futuristic i can't even
tell you right now go to lyft.com that's
lyft.com you get yourself a 500 new
driver bonus and you'll have a great job
that you can create the hours for and
work between gigs and whatever it's
really awesome
also if you want wine delicious wine
hand picks for you deliver to your front
door go to wink guys winc.com
they basically give you a palette
profile quiz you answer questions of
what you think tastes good random foods
doesn't have to do with wine just tastes
okay they collect the information and
they store the data about what your
mouth likes okay and then they go out
and pick wines based on that it's
scientific they're getting you ones that
they know you're gonna like and they're
delicious they're delicious
and then they send it to your house in a
nice package box you don't have to go to
the store you don't have to look at
labels anymore you just get the wine all
the hassle's done with it go to tri-wink
that's try winc.com to join for free
skip any month and cancel anytime guys
plus they have 100 satisfaction
guarantee so you never pay for a bottle
that you don't like and if you use our
awesome url go to
triwink.com and jillian they're giving
you 20 off your first order and they're
covering the shipping
i don't know how you can say no it's a
great deal
thank you for listening to the real
sponsors sorry yeah those are the real
stuff those are the responses thank you
lyft and thank you inc and thank you
lift and wink for letting us do vic
sponsors hopefully we we're not fired
yeah is this like a violation of having
sponsors i don't know we'll see i don't
think anyone ever explicitly is like
please don't also have fake sponsors
yeah anyway back to nightmare fuel okay
yeah
i want to create a volume 2 and i think
what i might do is i might just create
it and like quietly release it without
telling you yes please sneak up on it
just just sneak up
sneak up
okay
i'll record it
don't mind me i have to i have to get my
producer i don't know where he's been
it's been like three years since i've
talked
you're the producer the recording studio
you line up a couple mods in the session
make sure for like months beforehand you
post pictures at like four in the
morning with youth sunglasses on that
says i'm in the studio
no i'm just gonna i'm just gonna put my
phone up and self time and picture
myself i'm gonna say i'm just grinding
and then it's like in the studio
grinding then i'm gonna go like this i'm
gonna
flip the audio technica inside out go
grind it oh my god just like the audio
technica sparks well i mean if you're
gonna be grinding then you might as well
get yourself some all-natural lambskin
condoms they're just you know more
natural than latex condoms
you did not there's no allergies i said
grinding first it is completely not
vegan whatsoever since they're made out
of actual lamb skin but if you have a
latex allergy
safe sex shouldn't go into your vagina
and or penis with the latex it's not
good for it so get yourself
natural
is that the coffee they gave you yes
if you go to jennajillian.com
want the lambskin
how do you install that url can you
spell that url for us
www.http does that take you to a website
that enters the dark web hddp
colon slash slash backslash
it's forward
it's backslash and then a force that's
like a v
http
yeah
the hashtag
at the end
yes
all right did i do good on that one you
did good i'm proud of you thank you i'm
proud of you for doing the segways i
think you're doing good honey you're
doing great sweetie wait i said honey
you're doing great you're doing great
sweetie honey
honey you were wonderful honey you are
wonderful that's what i just did okay
for anyone that doesn't know what that
is that is very [ __ ] niche like
literally no one knows that yeah um but
what season was it like this i don't
remember
but if you look up on youtube if you
were ever interested which for no
there's no reason why you ever should be
but uh the jabberwockies on america's
best dance crew had uh like an
exhibition performance after one of aft
not the first season like the third or
fourth if you just look up baby walkie
it's the one where they come out they do
their little dance and then all of a
sudden they pull a little jabberwocky
out of the stereo and the little baby
jabberwocky starts [ __ ] crushing it
everyone loses their mind and then uh
they're all like cheering they're all on
their feet to have the jabberwocky's
back it was super exciting little mom is
over there like saying something dumb to
herself in the corner and then
all of a sudden the baby walkie pulls
off the mask and it's a little girl
and and and jc chazy just was like wow
it's so great to have you back blah blah
blah blah jason's jose stuff
honey you were wonderful oh my god it's
so it's so funny
it's really that's it that's the story
that's all that happened do you remember
the year that was like 2011 or 12 no
older newer
i don't know i think it was in 2012. why
because i remember i was in the gym
watching that no no no no no no opened
up my melatonin protein shake after my
vigorous workout i was watching the tv
in the gym i watched that moment exactly
happened
to a d and then i drank my melatonin
protein shake by bodybuilding.com
you drink your melatonin protein shake
you get the muscle recovery and you go
right to [ __ ] sleep yeah i have a lot
of questions yeah ask me questions i'm
the expert and creator and ceo of
melatonin
literally no one takes melatonin for a
nap
i i do and i figured so many people
wanted to sleep for like eight hours a
night wake up that's not people
everywhere we're looking for ways to
recover from their workouts like what
better way to recover
no it's daytime you can only take in the
daytime if you take it at night it turns
into dust and you die
okay that sounds like a dangerous
process go to jennajillian.com
test or die marble test or die no dust
or die dust or die
just
eat the melatonin right now
and you get you get five percent on
when you go to
the tournament.com los angeles meeting
you're paying more okay you get five
percent on on your first order and on
the future orders it's normal price but
five percent on
let's go to melatonin.com and julian you
get a melatonin protein sheet
what better way to recover from your
just an ingredient in your product what
better way to recover from
your [ __ ] here we go
oh my god i wanted to disappear
vigorous workout okay
try melatonin protein shakes by going to
melatonin.com
it is such a good protein shake that you
were gonna want to pay more
okay it's only gonna feel right to pay
more for this thing
melatonin.net voices put them back
on dot gov
dot com yeah
back off what
anything like that
do you think you're not looking like
this without taking naps
oh they take 10 naps
but that's like
you're you're taking an anvil and you go
to ib
yeah what's what's weird about that
it's so stupid when i was in eighth
grade i bought melatonin.com as a domain
name and i've been paying fees on it
ever since oh my god
[Music]
you bought melatonin.com yeah
did you okay did i ever tell you that
what where are you going with this no no
okay
um in like
2011 or 12 or something like sort of
right when my channel started like
people were watching it
like somebody bought the domain name
jennamarbles.com yeah you told me about
this mine is jennamarblesblog.com
and at that time i i was still like i
don't remember what [ __ ] year it is
i'm like kind of losing my mind but like
i didn't have money like i wasn't really
making any money like i said
the first couple of videos get pretty
big and yeah but like it was like 300 or
something yeah and so the the person
that registered jennamarbles.com reached
out to me
and they were like hey i'm willing to
sell you this domain and i'm like
i mean okay i mean it's not cool that
you registered it anyways like i was
literally just gonna do that once i got
some money together to help get someone
to help me yeah and they're like yeah
i'll sell it to you for fifty thousand
dollars so that's like oh my god
like please keep it what the [ __ ] what
kind of money you think i'm [ __ ]
making is that correspondence happen
over email i think so i wonder if you
still have that email
be interesting to see yeah maybe i don't
know but um
scumbag
well i just i think it's just somebody
that like does that kind of thing yeah i
mean it's smart you know it's probably
paid off for them i guess it would not
have come back yeah no but like
even it's been like a couple years after
that or whatever when they like
revisited it and then they wanted to
sell it again and i'm like i don't want
to buy it like
it's been like
i'll give it to you for five percent off
you want to know
but like it's it's been this long
without having it like i i really i
don't want it it's all yours dude i'm
sorry that it didn't pay off for you 10
off
40 000
boy where did you come up with that
[ __ ] price
i don't know dude but it's like telling
a 22 year old or something 35 45 yeah
they're like oh yeah i'll buy it from
you and you have like nothing you're
like struggling to get your dollar bills
and cash together to pay your rent and
they're like yeah i'll still let you for
fifty thousand dollars of like boy
oh my god that's premium right there
like how would i ever make fifty
thousand dollars from my website unless
you're like you have a store or like
merch or something but like i wasn't
selling anything and it was basically a
website it was he was doing what he
probably makes a lot of money off that
because he probably reserves domains
that a lot of people with a lot of money
yeah so i mean good on you for getting
melatonin.com when you were in i didn't
i did it i didn't do it that was a
complete lie i never did that i didn't
buy domains up i didn't even have money
to do that but no
no
melatonin.com
it's my homepage
is that a real website
i don't know probably what about
melatonin.gov
and melatonin.edu is taken i think oh
damn damn it cause the education of
melatonin is important
it's a new subject
oh
how you doing over there that's good
yeah just hanging out having a good day
i'm having a great day we just uh hung
out we took the dogs to the park it's a
basketball game tomorrow took the dogs
to the park we met two wiggies at the
park yep louie and ziggy they were
really cute really really cute peach was
like running all over the um agility
course there's like a little agility
course in the dog park that we go to
that is probably better suited for the
big dog park yeah but it doesn't yeah
but it doesn't look like they have any
over there
like agility so it makes me feel like
somebody that loves that dog park that
has little dogs
donated it to the little dog park and
literally none of the little dogs go on
any of it but peach is so [ __ ] good
at it and everyone always looks over
like you know they all have dogs like
marbles and they're like come on
but i mean it's an extreme sport and if
you're looking to do extreme sports but
you you got you periods that you should
get you some tan tags in streams for it
yo but when you ride on your motorcycle
or you [ __ ] you just
dragging a monster truck
maybe you're gonna miss
who
knows your best extremes
do it low i want a low one
extreme
sport
if you got your
my
god
if you got your flow if you got your
vote make sure you know
the sport
featuring
quadruple absorbency
cotton it will never come out
[Laughter]
that's horrifying maybe
oh my god okay
if you no put it back
if you the kind of girl that knows
you're never gonna do anything with your
vagina again
what's the url for people to go to
tampax extremesport.com
cool t-e-s
test forever
no you're done this segway is over you
you have lost this that was
tess i want my voice
test forever.com
diet coke
you can't bring coke back
i double-sided you
can't believe it
you put it up
[Music]
i'm turning this off now
that was good you um you are a natural
with the segways thank you i love your
delivery because when you're crying
screaming laughing it somehow makes the
segway just so much better
what can i say maybe we should trade
maybe i'll do the sponsors maybe
well this box sure doesn't hurt look out
baby you've got competition the voices
help the segways i love the voices yeah
this box is definitely premium you know
what else is premium no caiman jerky and
what better jerky to get than jared's
caiman jerky
caiman jerky i don't know i feel like he
this boy eaten jared
i don't know i feel like it's kind of
close right after i
guys if you want to go camping by a
swamp with a family of alligator and
kill the smallest one and eat it in
front of the bigger ones then you're the
type of person that needs to buy jared's
cayman jerky today only in stores but
also only online
jared's came cayman jerky
is this boy eating jared for real dot
com gov slash jenna julian
once you go to the website
your coordinates your current geographic
coordinates will be sent to the nearest
cayman the king will run to your house
and talk to you a little bit and then
you get to eat them and then you eat the
jerky in front of them no no
the katelyn or the cayman is dressed up
in a door-to-door salesman outfit he's
delivering you jared oh okay they're all
okay they've understood now that there's
jared's chair is a product okay
are you sure that you're eating jared
every time you open it well the first
chair that was killed and eaten was so
delicious that half of them was
preserved and they took the formula and
oh my god now every cayman jerky has
jared's flavor yeah nasty
jesus is only available online but also
only available in stores and also only
available at the flea market and maybe
also 7-eleven sometimes jennajillian.com
jared
j-a-r-a-a-d
every kiss begins with cherish he went
to german
this boy went to jared
this is the dumbest [ __ ] ever buy my
cannon jerky with your money
too big streams
my mouth
[Music]
you're [ __ ]
is that all of yours
yeah
how do you feel i think you did really
well i think you made you laugh more
than i've ever seen anyone make you
laugh
that's probably true
and when people are always like even
when we watch like the wheel or like the
shows where people have to survive alone
and they're like yeah it's just so
terrible like being isolated like it's a
genuine form of torture to be like
isolated from society and like never
talk to anyone i really genuinely feel
like for a certain amount of time i'd be
like more than fine because like i'm i
crack me up so hard you crack yourself
up the only person that cracks you up
more than you is me like how many times
do you find me around the house she was
like singing myself a dumb song for like
12 hours straight
like i would be terrible on those shows
because they'd be like holy [ __ ] shut up
she's not losing her mind she's
perfectly fine she came in on day one
like this and is the [ __ ] same just
worse
me
me as [ __ ] damn
well hopefully you guys enjoyed this
podcast i think this was really a goofy
one i thoroughly enjoyed it i did too um
also if you could please give us some
feedback on the audio is it loud is it
quiet is it crisper is it not as crisp
like we're really working on this we're
going to try to perfect this setup over
the next few episodes so that we can
have an improved uh product for you guys
i like having voices too i imagine we'll
do them less and less yeah we're not
going to do them like this every episode
but but they're really fun right now
because we've never had them before yeah
right yeah that's right that's right i'm
going to be gone
next week no
but i'll we'll still have a podcast
ready for you guys i know i know um
i
uh
august 21st i encourage if anyone is in
the path of totality to find the solar
eclipse that's where i'm going
to uh film and find i'm kidding i love
you and i'm kind of jealous no i
definitely think if anyone can watch it
you should do it yeah that's pretty
awesome but we'll be back next week for
another podcast i hope you guys have a
great week we're on twitch all the time
so check us out there too yeah we live
you know
all right guys
dank day see you guys later
bye bye
bye
bye oh sorry oh
go
bye
one more tampax extreme one more all
right i gotta think of one just give me
a second wait you gotta make it low i
like it low
hell yeah don't you know
oh [ __ ]
yo i'm a girl
[Music]
i put
[Music]
sick but i also can't help children or
do anything with my vagina that's okay
because i decided a long time ago
i do multiple kids to people in the face
and i ride a motorcycle i only do
extreme things i never needed eat my
redemption okay
i'm so sorry for everything
i'm the worst place i know i'm so sorry
we'll see you guys next week
[Music]
[Music]
you